how did you decide on the name  [Laughter]  [Applause]  hodor  that's not his real name that's just  what they call him  his real name is walder if you're named  walder you might want to be called photo  or two  uh i don't know you have to keep reading  okay  that question and soon  [Music]  we had this meeting with george martin  where we're trying to get as much  information as possible out of him and  probably the most shocking revelation he  had for us  it was when he told us the origin of  hodor how that name came about  i just remember dana looking each other  when he said that just being like holy  [Music]  [ __ ]  it was just one of the saddest and most  affecting things  even sitting in a hotel room and having  somebody tell you that this was going to  happen  in the abstract in some way and that  hold the door was the origin of  the name hodor we just thought that was  a really  really heartbreaking idea  oh